I can't do this I'm sorry it's not fair
buddy it's not fair
the first thing they've asked for oh
buddy yeah what the [ __ ] is that man are
they treating this like a game is this
like a game to them it's like let's see
if we can do crack tonight
I just want to laugh
after all right that's just insane you
know
listen I see what you're going through I
understand fully now okay it's a
disaster
I've never seen such a fragmented
business my God
and the chefs like that
you think that's [ __ ] man it's
ridiculous I just I just finally cracked
I didn't think there's an habit when
he's been warning me that it's all just
being bottled up and you're just gonna
break down
here's the sad news no this is your
fault and yet you seem to be the only
one taking responsibility the mom and
dad are dreaming you know that I know
I know you're feeding their dreams and
getting yourself further and further in
shape you finally realize what's
happening so you've now got to take the
reins you've got no choice now
you have got to stand up on your own two
feet and not tolerate this [ __ ]
I'm crying come on come on come on
I've got your back
because I can see what it means to you
thank you that's all I can say thank you
but you're the only reason I'm staying
here I'm telling you thank you I don't
like you because you're sincere
you actually can pretty much have a
pretty big heart you do thank you thank
you for this
you know I've never had someone actually
like help you know
thank you
hang on in there okay
[Music]
after witnessing one of the most
dysfunctional restaurants he has ever
seen good morning come in come in please
take a seat Chef Ramsay knows it's time
for a not so subtle wake-up call first
of all I wanted to get you out of the
restaurant that was important yeah thank
you and what better way to do that than
bring you to an amazing little theater
and a little show we all like a show
right believe me this is quite a show
ladies and gentlemen may I present
the yelpus
good morning wow there's a Molly help us
Chef Ramsay had the absolute nerve to
reach out to the office they are
deliberately attacking my restaurant wow
they're the actual helpers every yelpert
lies they hurt and damage restaurants by
doing this okay Alan listen carefully
you were 100 convinced that those
negative reviews were part of a
conspiracy is there a plot against you
from Yelp to close this business no
question in my mind Alan does someone
I'd like you to meet this lady is the
community manager for Yelp Katie Burbank
hi Alan I know that you're very
frustrated but they're all real we're
all real all of our reviews mean
something it's feedback for you to use
however you'd like hi
um I'm a big Rooter for you guys I am
and I wanted to love your burger so bad
like I love burgers and I didn't came in
expected to spend 26 dollars on an
amazing Burger it uh wasn't amazing I
was expecting an explosion of flavor but
I pretty much didn't taste anything what
I got in the burger was an extremely
unflavorful huge piece of meat that had
the consistency of a nasty loaf of
Meatloaf I absolutely detest what's
served at your restaurant I'm not like
an avid yelpert in fact I created the
account
just to comment on your place because
that bird was so disappointing in the
end it was a big who smear of a horrible
experience I too signed up for Yelp just
to write a review and it was the one and
only Yelp review we have ever written
interesting that customers are perfectly
opening accounts to post a comment wrote
a review I received a response from you
that basically told me I didn't know
what I was talking about and it was
essentially my fault that I had a bad
review I wrote my review on Yelp only to
be met with sort of a barrage of emails
from you and you told me that you
thought we were good competition and you
told me that you thought we were out to
get you at one point you threatened to
turn us over to the hate crime division
of the LAPD instead of saying sorry come
back in I will make it better it was
kind of an attack and to me it felt like
maybe this place is hopeless because
they're not taking the criticism like is
this place doomed
um Jen am I keeping you up darling would
you like a blanket
I was angry at my mom for falling asleep
I don't know what she was trying to pull
there we've been here 10 minutes and I'd
like you to look good but to watch you
sit there and snore I think it's the
height of Bad Manners I was incredibly
frustrated I thought this is not gonna
work
unbelievable I mean unbelievable they're
customers no no no no no you're missing
my appointment this is what's driving me
nuts every single one of these people
here everywhere you you enough this is
ridiculous
have to stop caring about Yelp he's
trying to get you off of this [ __ ] man
I'm missing a point you are so obsessed
with this becoming five stars four stars
no it's an arbitrary number man you
you've learned about this so much and
these people are actually honest they
told you that they have a terrible
[ __ ] time
ridiculous you make excuses
[Music]
no no enough
Chef Ramsey gathered yelpers to prove to
the family and to the staff the real
damage they have caused to their
reputation you were 100 convinced that
those reviews weren't part of a
conspiracy and to show Alan that this is
not a conspiracy no no no no no you're
missing my point enough enough this is
ridiculous
these people are actually honestly told
you that they have a terrible [ __ ]
time this is ridiculous you make excuses
[Music]
no no enough
it's afraid to talk now especially the
way my son blasted me I don't he didn't
blast you he just told you that you're
worrying about the wrong things
okay there's someone I'd like you to
meet
the owner and the executive chef of The
Foundry on Melrose Eric good morning sir
Eric's gonna give you a little insights
to how he deals with Yelp
you know one of the things that I think
you always have to be very careful of
when it comes to y'all is you can't look
at these and take them as personal
attacks and try to adjust them at the
end of the day it's not personal if it
was personal they come up and tell to
your face you know I get one star
reviews I get five star reviews I get
the whole board you know even my my
grilled cheese sandwich everybody says
let's sandwich around people real
reviews and say it's the worst numbers
I've ever had what do I do do I change
the grilled cheese no but if 18 people
tell me my burger is under seasoned 18
of them are telling me that there's got
to be a problem and it's worth looking
at and like he said if there's 18
complaints about one particular item
trust me we've got it wrong so we moved
and we change course we take Yelp as an
advantage to reposition ourselves and we
listen to a consensus that's what we do
the only thing I ever get wrong on is I
don't like unfairness I was focused on
that wrongly and I apologize look any
review that you get from somebody is
feedback and if you're too obsessed
about why they're saying it and not what
they're saying you're gonna find
yourself in trouble thank you
Chef Ramsay maybe I'm obsessed and I'm
wrong I agree with you I'll never ever
speak about this again and I appreciate
it enormously because I hope we can
learn from this and improve
hopefully something got through to my
dad but he's stubborn the guy has a gift
of blissful ignorance a gift we have to
go back to the Russians and we've got a
lot to do I trust you're gonna give us
one more go Burger Kitchen and thank you
for your patience this morning giving up
your day and to be here thank you so
much thank you very much thank you
okay let's go now that Chef Ramsay has
gotten through to Allen about his
so-called Yelp conspiracy forget it okay
I'm gone from my mind we're over Yelp
[Music]
he now moves on to a much bigger problem
of the restaurant there's something else
that I need to talk to you all about
[Music]
there is so much tension in this
restaurant from this family it is
extraordinary and the only way this
business can move forward is if we clear
the air
first of all who runs the restroom who's
in charge of the restaurant really
by default it seems that I am I don't
want to be
come on you're serious
you went in full control he wanted full
control exactly you can do that's
exactly what I'm saying when is it
[ __ ] fire
now she listened do you not trust Daniel
I trust him a hundred percent
of course Whitney believes I don't
why don't you trust your father what is
the one big reason that you don't trust
him
I don't trust you because of how you
opened this restaurant
I put in 250 000 you put in 250 000
that's a total of 500 000. dad I never
put 250
000 into this
so you didn't give permission from your
father to
sort of look after no no no
I want to be on the paperwork I want
evidence of how much I actually own
that's why I put it with the account
well just always the same excuse me you
know maybe we need a new account Danny
is getting taken advantage of and he's
being worked his ass off and he's not
even given a chance to even like feel
bad excuse me Wendy you don't have a
right to be cruel I'm tired person
constantly you get paid he doesn't cash
register oh what do I get paid
[Music]
and then they say they repay themselves
this is a constant thing you are a liar
have you ever thought about giving him
anything for the money
to me
you're an outright liar enough
Chef Ramsay has called a family meeting
to clear the air have you
but it's quickly turned into a battle
between Daniel and Wendy you know what
Alan and Jen you're right
listen to yourself this is someone I
love very much and the way you treat her
is like [ __ ] and as long as you and Dad
I didn't like her and Wendy as long as
you dislike them this will never ever
ever
Daniel what do you want no seriously
what do you want
that's a very good question what does
Daniel want yeah no seriously what do
you want
I want you guys to stop like making
excuses and and going back on lies and
and trying to win you don't need to win
you know you don't need to be right all
the goddamn time all you have to admit
is that you know all you have to admit
is that what you did was wrong what you
did was really really wrong
shut up shut up
I live in this like depressed [ __ ]
world you know and all three of you on
the side are just killing me man you're
[ __ ] killing me you know you really
are you really really are
all right
I cannot do anymore
okay I just want I just I'm asking for
like a week a day
foreign
so for the sake of the family and the
potential
business can you just give him that
he'll deserve that now
how do I do that when I I don't believe
in that how do I you're asking me how
you gonna not be civilized don't fight
and just learn to walk away
we're in a dreadful predicament and it's
faster than got so much worse and it's
so sad to see a family ripped apart with
the viciousness
it is not necessary
you have to change your ways both of you
I got told to get back and read this on
my book
Euro book yeah gentle Satan it was about
my father that's what my mother called
him I stayed up to four o'clock this
morning because it's almost like I was
living it live yet I was seeing a
reenact of the same scenario
I mean let me read you a few uh extracts
he hates me to build out on his behavior
especially by his son
[Music]
was caught in a tug of war between my
mother and father
does this sound familiar yes
he didn't listen to anyone else his
opinion and he did as he chose
in his business ventures
[Music]
and I'm sorry to tell you this but
you've got to listen it's a sequel but
it's live and it's going on in these
four walls yes it is
like father like son
I see exactly what Chef Ramsey has
brought up I mean it
I was wrong
it's irrelevant
of everything else
but I apologize to both of you
all of my heart I have done the wrong
thing if we can't get together we might
as well just close the door now
[Music]
that's the smartest thing you've said
since I've been through these doors we
we need to draw a line in the sand
forgive and forget and move forward and
that's exactly what Daniel's asked you
to do I will do my best
forget the business the most important
thing in life is family
now maybe we can begin yeah and moving
forward and focus on the restaurants
okay
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you
it's hard for a father to do that to
admit to a son that he made a terrible
mistake and I admitted it I want to
freeze this moment because it's the
first actually like time that you three
of you have actually gotten along for
more than like 15 seconds Timmy listen
to me I swear on my life I meant every
last word every last word of what I mean
I believe it there is no question in my
mind
this day should have happened long ago
[Music]
after what appears to be a major
breakthrough with the family Chef Ramsay
can finally turn his attention to the
food we'll go through and train okay so
we know how to cook a burger okay
let's do a new classic burger first of
all a nice season lightly brush oil and
the nice exciting thing about these
Burgers is freshly ground meat 15 fat so
they're full of flavor something with
your Frozen burgers were lacking guys I
want you guys to learn everything I feel
like I'm learning a lot watching Chef
Ramsay medium rare medium and well done
it's going to take all of that
information and run the restaurants as
best as I can
and then back okay let's go
[Music]
okay ladies take a slice and dig in
the new blend of the special burger with
uh Chef Ramsay's touch that's very nice
it's a pretty Fabulous Burger this is
amazing wow so good this is amazing
price is good too
the burger that we had was way better
than our old Frozen patties That's a
classic burger and put on a special in
place of the classic tonight but that's
just the first step we have a million
more miles to walk I know it's just a
small change but it's in the right
direction okay classic burger
[Music]
the mood is already different for
tonight's dinner service just stay
intense with the specials Daniel is
clearly inspired hey Chef okay bye Chef
Ramsay really one first Expediting
Daniel okay do you give an answer yes
chef yes yes it made me feel great when
uh Chef Ramsay seemed to have the
confidence in me to run things but I
really really hope that my parents step
aside
welcome to Burger Kitchen
okay we are running a special tonight
we're doing a new ground chuck steak
blend burner and then it also comes with
fries I'm gonna try the specials the
special please it's one of the classic
specials okay bought her up two specials
right now and then our regular stuff a
California on an iPhone let's get those
onion rings out now
played all those fries for the special
right now we got three going out perfect
you're about to see a [ __ ] miracle
come on let's go first first class Excel
they wanted medium rare yeah thanks to
Daniel's leadership in the kitchen food
is making its way out to the dining room
and while Chef Ramsay's special is a hit
it's a natural look like ground beef is
not very good very planned items from
the old menu are getting the same old
complaints
those are too spicy No One's Gonna put
that in their mouth huh other times
you're terrible like that I know but we
ought to embrace change now man gotta
change gotta change okay jalapeno I'm
gonna need a knee drop sweet potato
fries regular fries it hasn't been made
because there's lots of [ __ ] sides oh
my God we have no Organization no system
everything just became a [ __ ]
again
did you get those onion rings to table
12 ever
hello I hope so I'd put them out you put
them out uh let me see this system is so
[ __ ] up dude so too sweet one fried no
one sweet two fry one potato skin one
onion ring there we go let's get back on
track right now okay onion rings good I
need oh perfect well Daniel is on his
way to reorganizing the kitchen where's
those onion rings onion rings on the fly
please you just repeated exactly what I
said Alan feels the need to step in and
help stay at your position I am today is
your position
my dad keeps going back to that same old
thing where's the the confidence I want
to be confident okay we're missing onion
rings for table 12. he's dead he's
stubborn and he's unwilling to change
it's very infuriating can you pick these
two burgers
42. okay table
um 42 has been waiting for a very long
time just setting their owner out if he
continues to come back here and ask for
onion rings or whatnot I'm done he needs
feedback but just rather than go in
there they've been waiting how long 24
it's just gone just gonna I'm gonna get
in that Spirit of working for each other
you know like so going in there and
dropping negatives after negative and
then I'm trying I really after this I
never only just try it a different way
it's your son he's not your Chef he's
your son service servers Chef Ramsay is
right like father like son okay
everyone's doing a great job we're
getting out much faster than we were
last night and I gotta stop it right now
because I don't want my son to be like
me and in turn pass it on to his child
with Allen taking a back seat that's it
specials are all sold that's all
good I think we're done
Daniel pushes the last orders out thank
you very much for coming thank you thank
you welcome
let me say one thing at least that was
better than last night yeah and from
last night yeah
um was I proud of tonight no there's
still a lot that we need to improve I
agree but you know what that's a great
position for you in there because you're
in control and you sound and look like
an owner okay good job thank you thank
you tomorrow we are saying goodbye to
the past and we are relaunching this
restaurant I got some serious work to do
good night I'll see you in the morning
thank you Sean okay thank you good night
Chef
after a draining few days Chef Ramsay's
crew Works through the night to
transform this non-descript restaurant
into a trendy La hangar
[Music]
let's go good morning hi good morning
let's be honest yesterday we clearly
took a big turn for the good today is
about saying goodbye to the past and
opening the door to the new chapter of
the Burger Kitchen let's go let's go
let's go let's go
[Music]
it's unbelievable welcome to the new
Burger Kitchen
let's start off with those amazing new
murals on the wall look at them no more
ugly green balls no more ugly green
Walls the atmosphere beforehand was so
depressing unbelievable now we have pop
art they're hip they're cool and they're
very trendy incredible this is
unbelievable oh my God no more booths
this is incredible Danny over here is a
chalkboard where we can go and have some
fun on there so we are only as good as
our last Burger it's interactive you can
leave messages that you can recommend
wow Wild Things unbelievable
I am I am I'm very I it just it looks
great I honestly feel that this place
has urban street appeal I sound like a
tool saying that but that's the industry
you have to look hip and you have to
look cool if you feel like you can bring
your girlfriends now finally finally I
feel like happy to work here it no
longer looks like tacky cheese ball 80s
disgustingness it looks like Trinity
cool restaurant so in keeping with the
trendy dining room I want to introduce
you to a very cool state of the heart
unique point of sale system this thing
is extraordinary oh my God it's provided
by Zephyr hardware and it is POS lava it
is incredible ladies you're at the table
with your alignment touch screen device
[Music]
you just press it but it comes up in
front of them and the kitchen gets
information running around with the
tickets stressing out to hell what in
the [ __ ] are all these tickets here this
is ridiculous game of Solitaire
I could swipe credit cards inventory can
be checked out against your purchasing
you bring in the beers it gets entered
in and you get a daily stop take I
believe you can monitor it from your
wireless computer anywhere in the world
I have no one in your area has this wow
wow wow I can't thank you enough I
really can't I can't thank you enough
man this is
[Music]
don't cry come on don't cry don't cry
don't you alright Alan you okay yeah
yeah you're sure fantastic well I just
wanted to liven the place up a little
bit and bring some some excitement in
here with that depressing green Wall
come on that's incredible it was nice to
see if my Dow shows some emotion it was
he genuinely seemed happy he really
actually seemed happy this is incredible
this is a hundred
times better
now the Burger Kitchen has a cool new
look Chef Ramsay has come up with a menu
to match I take him on your possum along
please have a look at menu number 23
everybody
that looks great it's small it's Dynamic
and more importantly it is delicious wow
right here we go nibbles okay we have
sweet potato fries all natural fries
parmesan fries and they are hand cut
delicious next up we have a vodka
battered onion rings delicious for the
table vodka batter wow that's a that's a
damn good idea way to taste them Burgers
start off with the classic America we've
got that amazing Pate 15 fat short rib
chuck and a 10 dry age just to keep you
quiet
not touch that recipe let me tell you no
it's a great recipe oh my God if he
touches it keep your paws off it put
your right hand up hi Alan will not
change the Pate I Alan swear to God I
will change nothing lovely excellent yes
yes finally okay we've got the most
amazing lamb burger delicious low in fat
and this one's done with a really
classic tzatziki sauce next to that a
West
sharp cheddar delicious fried onion
rings and that's served with a very rich
homemade barbecue sauce I love this I
love this Asian persuasion yes Asian
style beef Pate Cherokee glaze with a
delicious Asian slaw can we eat I want
to eat I want to try this food put your
knife and pork dive in and enjoy
ment those are bombs I'm out of control
again wow
you'd be stupid to think it's not good
it's fabulous
oh God just come running here
immediately it's one of the best burgers
I've ever tasted in my life it's
Sensational I will never need to change
the menu again
[Music]
clearly Burger Kitchen now has something
it never had a sense of hope okay ready
but Chef Ramsay has some important news
to share with the staff
and as you all know we've been through
some major changes and we have made a
significant a significant step in the
right direction
do you know that in a year and a half
this restaurant managed to sort of
self-inflict its dwindling reputation
tonight you have a big second chance
it's not only relaunch night
but I have filled this restaurant with
it's relaunch night at the Burger
Kitchen tonight you have a second chance
and the pressure is already on but Chef
Ramsay has some important information to
share it's not only renal tonight but I
have filled this restaurant
with serious bloggers
coming to die tonight
yo tasting table ciao Urban Spoon
Serious Eats LA and Blackboard eats this
is the night you can transform this
business all or nothing there's no
rehearsal so get real and get a grip we
are now getting together an enormous
amount of critics all in one night we
deliver we're set for life we cannot
screw up at all Daniel yes anything you
want to say to the team here's how it's
going to work tonight dad you're gonna
be behind the bar don't host Tonight
I'll be Expediting Mom you can host
tonight
good luck everybody let's go do this
guys come on let's do this all right
[Music]
you guys ready make me proud Hi how are
you welcome to Burger Kitchen
thank you for coming brand new redesign
new menu I'm sure you'll have a great
time California already how would you
like to cook [ __ ]
the classic good choice I can't even
believe this is the same restaurant
I know right finally the new POS is
fantastic makes me happy it's gonna make
me more positive when I see tables
does it really bothering you all right
first order you're exercising good
excellent we have got to step up tonight
we got a Juicy Lucy well we need to just
focus on what I told everyone to do
first oh they're ready and if they do
that I think we'll be doing great find
slime start taking them come back just
come back one by one the kitchen is off
to a fast start
and the Divine swine burgers are making
their way out to the diners
and the early reviews are promising
yeah there's your classic there's your
Western comeback for your sauces then
come back for your pork and even though
Daniel has the kitchen running smoothly
excuse me Danny what we are missing
hanging rings and house pickles at the
bar okay you heard that onion rings and
house pickles for the bar Allen has left
his post at the bar and his back worry
is not wanted 31 brownies tell their
onion rings together go away Dad please
please move Daniel wanted me just behind
the bar the bottom line is you can't
stop me going to mingle with the
customers how's everything over here
okay okay very good thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you I'm an
owner I'm not a vegetable I was going to
get you another helping someone said you
were still hungry
don't worry about it
I'm in a Range
in the park please okay
Ally was bothering tables and he gets in
the way and it's too much how is the
order coming for them behind the bar
behind the bar for this place to succeed
Alan needs to go you sure 31. there's no
one at 31. bring it back bring it back
with me ice cream cookie you got it
Danny oh my gosh this is worship number
31 there's no one at 31. there's a 31
that's 31 there for four gentlemen
stay at the bar do you see how you miss
totally messed things up there's no 31
that's 31.
go near it okay fine Julia didn't
understand
Daniel is now focused on his father
instead of the kitchen
where's done
advised burgers are making their way out
to influential bloggers where is uh
where's Daniel don't come over here
I have to come over to get beer this is
a huge night for us and my dad is
driving me crazy right now if he
continues to get us all off our game
then it's really really bad he's
around
your machine yeah let me have them fix
this one then
[Music]
sorry yeah what do we go this is too
rare oh look at this come on guys
look what you're doing to us
it's raw
[ __ ]
down and focus
it's relaunch night at the Burger
Kitchen and while Daniel's attention is
diverted to his father stick to the plan
where's done food is still managing to
go out
let me have them fix this one then but
unfortunately without Daniel's quality
control a burger is coming back this is
too rare
oh look at this come on guys look what
you're doing to us it's raw slow down
and focus I'm sure they're important to
keep in mind the [ __ ] bar yeah please
go away Dad please okay fine so that's
so dead set in his way he's not doing
any benefit but causing Mayhem
and it's irrelevant when you're
Expediting you're at the helm what we
did to Dad is exactly we've got to do
more of and I've kind of triggered
something in me and I said you know what
Chef Ramsay is very very talented he
believes in me yeah we find that classic
America medium rare 43. I really have to
take the reins it's the only way the
place is going to work I need that pork
in Asian as fast as possible
with Daniel back in control of the
kitchen jalapeno for 43 I need my fries
my chips and my fried pickles and his
father entrenched at the bar orders are
correctly making their way to the hungry
critics here we go so sorry about that
that should be high yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let me tell you that and the Burger
Kitchen is on its way this restaurant
can work
but
we cannot afford to go back our old way
and the minute we do
we're screws
Daniel proven to me he has the
capabilities of running this place he's
amazing thank you let him do it with all
due respect this is Daniel's ration to
run
and there can only be one leader
cannot interfere and intervene I will
not promise
[Music]
I promise
my son had always made a good impression
with people but Chef Ramsay saw more
than that and more than even I saw that
my son could lead and run a restaurant
I'm sorry but this is the best advice
okay
I can give you
all I want to say is this I am thankful
to you well I'm grateful everything
that's happened because now I feel like
we've got a makings of a success and I
give it to my son with the greatest joy
wow thank you and I know your heart's in
the right place wow Chef Ramsay is right
I know that my son can handle it after
watching him in the relaunch of our new
restaurant that was a job well done as
you might have a two-minute conversation
with Daniel please yes of course thank
you very much look after yourself
okay
[Music]
a few words of advice yeah my father
died at 53.
think get a chance to say what I need to
say and make up with him before he
passed away
you
may never forget what he did to you
but you have to forgive him and you have
to move on yeah okay don't forget I
won't I won't but forgive okay yes yes
make sense absolutely absolutely I'll do
that I believe in you
I
know
I know wow you can't make this a success
it felt really good it's every single
emotion you would feel when someone of
that caliber you know puts that on you
and says you can do it thank you thank
you thank you thank you
foreign
Kitchen Nightmares I've ever done Daniel
may have been dragged into the business
but right now he's the only one who can
save it he has all the tools to make it
work it just needs to be left alone to
do it
22 menus
wow what a week
after Chef Ramsay left there you go guys
enjoy Alan and Jen kept the promise and
left the business in Daniel's hands
Danny is in charge I am passing the rain
100 to him under Daniel's leadership
Maryland run this to 21 jalapeno turkey
Divine swine the Burger Kitchen is
generating a ton of positive buzz in the
neighborhood as the go-to place for an
awesome Burger
it's everything all made in-house Chef
Ramsay did more than anyone could ask
for he's saving his restaurant and he'd
save the relationship I have with my
family
foreign